that that I came across while I was
training the first question is how
excited am I to play black Adam I am so
excited to play black Adam so excited so
pumped up so ready so focused so I don't
have the vocabulary at times to say that
did I am about black Adam how's it going
everybody it's Warren welcome back to my
channel and what you just saw was a
video that the rock released yesterday
where he talked about a lot of details
about the upcoming blackout of movie it
was the rock doing a Q&A answering
questions about black Adam and I'll play
the whole thing for you in just a second
this movie has been talked about for
over 10 years the rock signed on to play
this over 10 years ago but in this video
the rock talks about how now he's more
ready than ever to play the character he
also goes in and talks about what we can
expect as far as black Adams origin
story and he does confirm that this is
going to be an origin story he goes on
to talk more about what we can expect as
far as the plot is concerned about the
movie and then he even goes on to tease
Superman a little bit now he does go on
to say it's a joke however we know that
Shazam is going to go up against Black
Adam at one point and we do have reports
one from Mikey Sutton that says Henry
Cavill Superman may not be done yet and
could appear with Shazam and Black Adam
in a movie which would ultimately be the
final movie between Shazam Black Adam
and Superman
we have Shazam there's going to be black
Adam there's going to be Shazam - and
then in Shazam 3 it's already confirmed
that the rock is going to go up against
Shazam and perhaps Superman could make a
cameo in that film or the next one but
here's the rock himself talking about
what to expect a black Adam has been
with me for over 10 years now and that
gives you an idea of how passionate I am
about this project how passionate our 7
bucks is about this project Warner
Brothers New Line Cinema's DC they have
been so incredibly supportive over the
years I mean this is over 10 years in
2008 is when we first started talking
about this so it has required a patience
by all of us as partners as many of you
know Black Adam is a super villain from
the world of the DC Universe
and you know I'm a much different man
and an actor than I was ten years ago
and I felt ten years ago that even then
ten years ago I just wanted to wait till
for the timing to feel right and it
feels like now the men that I've become
you know I'm able to bring a little bit
of my own life lessons and philosophies
and ingrain them in the DNA of this
character and as those of you who
followed the mythology of Black Adam and
in the comics which is millions of you
and for those of you don't know Black
Adam there's a lot of deep layers to
Black Adam he is a man who is his
Constitution and his wiring and his
makeup is one of resolve and it is one
of a boundless anchor if you will and he
started off as a slave there's there's
some dark elements to Black Adam and you
know one of the things that I really
loved about the character of Black Adam
is that he was blessed by the Wizards by
the gods of four powers and his powers
equal that of Superman which
automatically you know makes him
intriguing to me and but he was also
bestowed a equalizing power and that
equalizing power is Magic which is
certainly Superman's weakness and I'm
not I'm not setting up a showdown
between Black Adam and Superman maybe
down the road but right now I'm just
giving you guys context for those of you
who don't know on how powerful Black
Adam is and one of the most interesting
things about Black Adam to me is the
fact that when you compare him to
Superman Superman believes in truth and
justice and everyone gets their due
process even the bad guys who have done
a lot of damage at harm to the world and
Superman believes in bringing them to
justice and then if justice is served
properly the bad guys go to jail in the
case of Black Adam
who is a supervillain who then became a
antihero by the way our first version of
Black Adam is going to be his his origin
story so we're going to understand where
he came from as he made his way to
becoming black Adam but the difference
is you know with Black Adam if you wrong
black Adam and be wrong his family if
you harmed his family or if you harm his
people then he's not gonna send you to
jail he's gonna rip you in half
literally bang he's gonna rip you an ass
it's kind of dark but again that is
that's the core of who Black Adam is -
hope you enjoyed that video everybody
everyone stay safe out there be sure to
hit the like button if you enjoyed the
video and are excited for Black Adam and
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to DC Shazam and Black Adam and Superman
if he returns as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof